dibuje por aquí cuatro moléculas de
triglicéridos y puede ser que tú en
estos momentos me digas oye pero que no
se supone que los triglicéridos tienen
carbonos oxígenos e hidrógenos así como
en estas moléculas de aquí por acá
observo estos oxígenos de aquí pero en
donde quedaron los carbonos y los
hidrógenos y bueno mi respuesta es que
todos esos carbonos e hidrógenos están
descritos implícitamente aquí en estos
día gr más que son como la forma rápida
de describir a moléculas grandes y vas a
ver este tipo de diagramas muchísimo en
química química orgánica y biología pero
bueno el punto es que en cada una de
estas partes puntiagudas en cada uno de
estos vértices implícitamente tenemos un
carbono porque ahí tenemos un carbono
aquí también tenemos un carbono aquí y
otro carbono por acá y en todos estos
puntos de aquí y bueno al final de la
cadena si no tenemos una letra por aquí
también tenemos un carbono
así es que implícitamente tenemos un
carbono aquí y un carbón o acá y otro
carbono acá y acá y en cada uno de estos
piquitos y bueno seguramente también te
estás preguntando qué pasó con los
hidrógenos bueno pues estamos suponiendo
que todos los carbonos tienen cuatro
enlaces covalentes y si no está dibujado
alguno de los enlaces covalentes del
carbono entonces estamos suponiendo que
ese es un enlace con algún hidrógeno por
ejemplo en este carbono de aquí estamos
viendo a dos de sus enlaces covalentes
así es que vamos a suponer que sus otros
dos enlaces son con hidrógenos ok y lo
mismo sucede para este carbono de aquí
tiene otros dos enlaces con hidrógenos y
bueno por acá en el caso de este carbono
solo estamos observando uno de sus
enlaces covalentes así es que debe de
tener otros tres enlaces covalentes con
hidrógenos todos los carbonos y los
hidrógenos están aquí
solo que están expresados implícitamente
ahora seguramente has notado la
diferencia entre cada uno de esos
triglicéridos y bueno de hecho si no has
notado las diferencias te recomiendo que
le pongas una pausa y te pongas a pensar
en qué tienen de diferente estos cuatro
triglicéridos ok pero puede ser que te
salte a la vista inmediatamente este
triglicéridos tiene puros enlaces
simples mientras que éste triglicéridos
tiene un enlace doble y por acá tenemos
varios enlaces dobles al igual que aquí
este también tiene varios enlaces dobles
sin embargo estos dos triglicéridos
también son diferentes
ok vamos a hablar de sus diferencias más
adelante pero bueno podemos empezar por
observar que en este triglicéridos
hay estas curvas ok como que se dobla
mientras que este triglicéridos se
mantiene en cierto sentido derecho y
vamos a hablar más acerca de sus
diferencias más adelante mientras tanto
vamos a regresar a este triglicéridos
por aquí tenemos puros enlaces simples y
eso lo que significa es que tenemos
todos los hidrógenos que podríamos
llegar a tener otra forma de decirlo
sería decir que este triglicéridos está
saturado de hidrógenos y por eso es que
a este tipo de triglicéridos le llamamos
grasas saturadas grasas saturadas y
seguro has oído hablar acerca de este
término la mantequilla tiene grasas
saturadas y las grasas saturadas suelen
tener un estado sólido a temperatura
ambiente y la razón por la que son
sólidas a temperatura ambiente es porque
aquí estos carbonos están todos
enlazados con la mayor cantidad de
hidrógeno es posible y por lo tanto no
se forman curvas estorbosas están
bastante rectos y eso les permite tener
una densidad más alta lo cual hace que
generalmente tengan un estado sólido a
temperatura ambiente y bueno no me
quiero meter en toda la discusión
y las grasas saturadas son buenas grasas
malas grasas pero algunas veces dicen
que estas son grasas malas ahora no son
las grasas más malas okay las grasas
verdaderamente malas son estas de aquí
estás en efecto si son las peores grasas
pero bueno vamos a ver eso más adelante
porque mientras tanto aquí este
triglicéridos son grasas saturadas
porque están saturadas de hidrógeno
aunque ahí tienen la mayor cantidad de
hidrógeno que podrían llegar a tener
porque tienen puros enlaces simples
ahora por acá podemos ver que tenemos un
enlace doble aquí tenemos un carbono y
aquí también tenemos un carbono este
carbono
aquí estamos observando tres de sus
cuatro enlaces covalentes entonces solo
va a tener un enlace más con un
hidrógeno y lo mismo le pasa a este otro
carbono de aquí ok
estamos viendo tres enlaces covalentes y
ya sólo falta un enlace
covalente con un hidrógeno a diferencia
de los carbonos por aquí que tienen dos
enlaces con hidrógenos entonces esta
molécula de aquí no tiene todos los
hidrógenos que podría llegar a tener así
es que decimos que es una grasa
insaturada grasas
y saturadas porque hay grasa insaturada
porque no tenemos todos los hidrógenos
que podríamos llegar a tener ahora estos
enlaces dobles sobre todo en este
triglicéridos
pero también en este estos enlaces
dobles hacen que se formen estas curvas
de aquí y estas curvas no permiten que
tengan una densidad muy alta y por lo
tanto suelen encontrarse en estado
líquido a temperatura ambiente por aquí
en este triglicéridos tenemos varios
enlaces dobles y por lo tanto vamos a
decir que esta es una grasa
poliinsaturada también es una grasa
insaturada pero como tiene muchos
enlaces dobles decimos que es poli
insaturada grasas
poli
a tour hadas y como esta grasa
insaturada tiene un solo enlace doble
entonces decimos que es una grasa
monoinsaturada mono ahora una pregunta
que seguro podría estar pasando por tu
cabeza es porque cuando tenemos estos
enlaces dobles en esta molécula y en
esta molécula se forman curvas mientras
que en esta otra molécula de aquí no se
forma ni una sola curva aunque si tenga
estos enlaces dobles y la razón se debe
a nuestros buenos amigos cis y trans
siempre que tenemos un doble enlace en
una cadena digamos por ejemplo que aquí
tenemos una parte de la cadena y
entonces por aquí tenemos un hidrógeno
siempre que tenemos un doble enlace hay
dos posibles configuraciones puede
suceder que los dos pedazos de cadena
estén del mismo lado del enlace doble y
aquí tenemos un hidrógeno aunque hay
aquí están del mismo lado
doble y esta es una de las dos posibles
configuraciones o puede suceder que
tenemos nuestro enlace doble entre estos
dos carbonos por aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno y que el otro hidrógeno esté
del otro lado del enlace doble y por lo
tanto nuestras partes de cadenas de
carbono también están en lados opuestos
del enlace doble lo que ellos están en
lados opuestos del doble enlace y ahora
esto es importante porque los enlaces
dobles son rígidos ok no puedes rotar un
enlace doble
así es que estas configuraciones
realmente si importan ok si es
completamente distinta esta
configuración a esta de acá
estos son isómeros distintos ok y
depende si éstos están en lados opuestos
del doble enlace
si están en el mismo lado si están en el
mismo lado decimos que tienen una
configuración cis mientras que sí están
en lados opuestos decimos que tienen una
configuración trans ahora resulta que la
mayoría de las grasas insaturadas
creadas de forma natural están en una
configuración cis y justo porque están
en una configuración silis cada que nos
encontramos con un enlace doble se forma
una curva y si tienes muchos enlaces
dobles como por aquí entonces
encontramos muchas curvas por lo que las
grasas poliinsaturadas es mucho más
probable que las encontremos en estado
líquido porque son mucho más difíciles
de empaquetar y ahora qué es lo que está
pasando por aquí bueno pues cada uno de
estos enlaces dobles está en la
configuración en la que las dos partes
de la cadena de carbonos están en lados
opuestos del doble enlace ok por ejemplo
por aquí esta parte de la cadena
esta podríamos decir que por encima del
enlace doble mientras que esta otra
parte de la cadena está por debajo del
enlace doble porque ellos están en lados
opuestos del doble enlace así es que
están en configuración trans y aquí no
se forma ninguna curva pero es por esta
configuración trans de los enlaces
dobles que se les llama a estos
triglicéridos grasas trans ok estas son
las famosas grasas trans y generalmente
no las encontramos en la naturaleza
ahora algo que es súper interesante
acerca de las grasas trans es que en
algún momento hubo algunas personas que
dijeron oye esto de las grasas saturadas
realmente no es bueno para nuestra salud
cosa que por cierto el día de hoy está
en debate algunos piensan que no son
realmente malas pero algunas personas
dijeron tal vez no deberíamos estar
comiendo tanta mantequilla y todo ese
tipo de cosas
entonces por qué no tomamos una de estas
grasas poliinsaturadas que si son buenas
para nuestra salud y las saturamos de
hidrógeno de forma que podamos obtener
una grasa sólida ha estado ambiente y
podemos cocinar con ella y reemplazar a
la mantequilla ok de hecho hace 10 o 15
años se podía encontrar este tipo de
grasas en todos lados hoy en día también
las puedes encontrar y entonces llegaron
a estas personas tomaron grasas
poliinsaturadas les echaron un bonche de
hidrógenos y bueno estos hidrógenos si
llegan y rompen algunos de estos enlaces
dobles pero también hacen que otros de
estos enlaces dobles cambien de tener
una configuración cis a tener una
configuración trans y bueno al principio
las personas decían sí seguro esto no
nos hace daño para nada incluso hasta de
ser más saludable para nosotros
gracias tienen ahora unas propiedades
parecidas a las de las grasas saturadas
son sólidas y muy parecidas a la
mantequilla pero siguen sin estar
completamente saturadas y además
seguramente es más fácil de producir las
podemos producir a partir de algunos
otros aceites oye estas grasas parecían
ser buenísimas tenían todas las
propiedades deseadas de las grasas
saturadas son sólidas y muy parecidas a
la mantequilla y además no están
completamente saturadas por lo cual uno
podría creer que son más saludables sin
embargo actualmente sabemos que no son
saludables y si es cierto hay muchos
debates nutricionales al respecto pero
definitivamente son grasas que no son
buenas para tu salud no las podemos
encontrar en la naturaleza y de hecho
hay varios estados y países que prohíben
definitivamente las grasas trans incluso
he escuchado a algunas personas decir
que son como veneno
a tu cuerpo y que te afectan de formas
realmente muy negativas y bueno la
verdad estoy exagerando bastante pero
pues es porque te quiero asustar un poco
así es que no comas grasas trans pero
espero que se haya disfrutado este vídeo